the Kansas City Chiefs mount a
fourth-quarter comeback to win the Super
Bowl
NFL ratings are up and Republican
senators unexpectedly whipped the votes
to exonerate president Trump and end
impeachment once and for all we will
examine the secret behind three dramatic
comebacks then Democrats freaked out
just hours before the Iowa caucuses
happening in in the next right now I
guess the halftime show highlights the
difference between sexiness and
pornography there's a huge difference
and brexit comes off without a hitch all
of that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
huge win in the Super Bowl and I don't
know anything about football I didn't
watch most of the Super Bowl but there
was a major win the biggest win of the
Super Bowl
was for us we all won the Super Bowl
because of how apolitical it was the
commercials the show itself everything
about it was not dripping in leftism we
will examine why that is because it made
the whole thing much much more enjoyable
but first I've got to keep you safe and
one way that I can do that is by telling
you about our friends over at ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
now you already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere
well what ring does is helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world you might recall that I have been
in Washington DC now for about three
weeks because we've been covering
impeachment on the Ted Cruz podcast well
one way that I can feel like I'm not so
far from home is ring-ring just keeps
you safe right now as a listener you
have a special offer on a ring starter
kit that is available right now take
advantage of this I've given ring out to
my friends and it really makes them feel
safe the video gets uploaded to the
cloud and they know whether they got a
burglar going around their house at
night or whether it's just a cute little
possum that's a true story with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home go to ring.com
slash knowles kano wles that is ring.com
slash knowles
big Superbowl win yesterday not just for
the Chiefs but for all of us the show
the game the spectacle was not political
it was not leftist it was not
anti-american it was not protesting the
American flag it was just football okay
there were ads for a president Trump
there's an ad for him and ad for
Bloomberg mostly other than that it was
free of politics the ads they were fun
they were kind of hokey they were kind
of lame well that's pretty much the
definition of television
these days in the age of new media
almost everything on TV is a little
hokey and a little bit lame but they
were fine why did the NFL avoid politics
the NFL avoided politics because
politics was destroying their ratings
leftism was destroying their ratings
Colin Kaepernick and protesting the flag
and all that stuff was causing people to
tune out and so the NFL made a big
comeback by getting rid of their
political advertising and political
themes the whole theme of today is
comebacks maybe the whole theme of this
year is major comebacks there was one
insane political ad that PETA the animal
rights organization wanted to put out
the NFL refused they said no we'll get
to that one in a little bit because it's
truly unbelievable
so yeah you had two ads basically there
were political Trump and Bloomberg now I
want to take a look at those before we
get to the the biggest comebacks because
those two ads show you completely
different strategies completely
different approaches to politics and I
think maybe why President Trump is gonna
have the advantage in November you know
yesterday was Groundhog Day too so we're
all making predictions here I think if
we're just judging by these two
political ads Trump is gonna have the
advantage in November so here is the
Trump ad it's a 30-second spot touting
his criminal justice reform
[Music]
I'm free to hug my family and I'm free
to start over this is the greatest day
of my life my heart is just bursting
with gratitude I want to thank President
Donald John Trump I'm Donald Trump and I
approve this message okay so that's the
ad right it's this this woman who has
been in prison for a long time for
running a drug operation and then Trump
lets her out of jail and this is
supposed to be a reason to vote for him
in November I personally don't like this
law I hated his criminal justice reform
also known as the jailbreak bill I think
it's been dishonest I think it it
distorts justice it's my least favorite
thing he's done probably however from a
political perspective this is a great ad
for the Super Bowl the reason this is a
great ad for the Super Bowl is because
it does not irritate Trump's base enough
to cause them not to vote for him I'm
not gonna not vote for Trump because he
passed one kind of stupid law that
doesn't really matter that much however
it's got a lot of crossover appeal it's
got a ton of crossover appeal to
independence and even some moderate
Democrats so it's it's a it's a big tent
political ad for the Super Bowl which is
one of the biggest TV events of the year
this ad also has an explicitly racial
appeal so the Democrats obviously have
been making race identity politics one
of the most important aspects of
politics for the past several decades
when it comes to the Super Bowl
that is how they injected politics in it
right Colin Kaepernick said that he was
protesting police brutality and racial
discrimination in law enforcement he
wasn't really protesting that he was
really protesting the American flag
which we found out when he protested the
Betsy Ross flag on a pair of Nike
sneakers when he became the Nike
spokesman so we know he's being
dishonest but at least what they were
saying overtly was that these protests
at the NFL were about racial
discrimination and then what Trump is
is appealing to an issue that is more or
less about racial discrimination in the
criminal justice system it's a very
smart way to get in there and flip the
script on the usual leftist identity
politics also it's a broadly popular
issue so-called criminal justice reform
or springing criminals from prison
especially if they're nonviolent drug
offenders which I think is a kind of
meaningless term but nevertheless these
are not people who have gone in and
murdered somebody they they've dealt in
drug crimes of course I think that all
drug crimes are violent because they
cause violence in the countries of
origin and they do actually cause
violence in the United States however
neither here nor there when people hear
non-violent drug offense they want mercy
for that person they want a little
leniency
it's a popular issue so Trump goes for
the popular issue okay compare that ad
to the other political candidates ad of
the Superbowl the other billionaire from
New York Mike Bloomberg here it is
George started playing football when he
was four years old he would wake up
every Saturday ready for the game that
became our life he had aspirations about
going to the NFL on a Friday morning
George was shot George didn't survive I
just kept saying you cannot tell me
that's a child that I gave birth to it
is no longer here
lives are being lost every day it is a
national crisis I heard Michael invert
speak he's been in this fight for so
long he heard mothers crying so he
started fighting when I heard my glass
stepping into the ring I thought now we
have a dog in the fight I know Mike is
not afraid of the gun lobby they're
scared of him and they should be okay it
goes on a little bit you get the gist
this is pretty much the polar opposite
type of political ad as president Trump
ran we'll get to how in line a second
first I have got to thank our friends
over at Rock Auto rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years which is
pretty much the entire history of the
internet go to Rock Auto calm right now
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet the thing I love about
rock Auto is they make it easy even for
me I don't know anything about cars when
my car breaks down I just think like up
well now it's broken I don't know what
do we do now but you got when you go to
an auto parts store brick-and-mortar you
go and you ask for the part they never
have the part in so what they do is they
go online they then mark up the prices
you pay a lot of extra money you don't
need to do that go to rockauto.com right
now you see all the parts available for
your car or truck catalog is super easy
to browse even I can do it when you go
and buy from there reliably fair prices
right in Noel's canna wles in there how
did you hear about us box that is
rockauto.com right in knowles and then
they will know that we sent you so
Bloomberg ears this this ad which is the
opposite of the Trump ad okay the Trump
ad criminal justice reform very
sympathetic looking person crossover
appeal just ideologically just broadly
popular the Bloomberg ad is about taking
your guns away
it's about depriving Americans their
second Amendment rights this is an
extremely polarizing issue
this this may be the most polarizing
issue in the entire country and I am
including abortion in that I'm including
very controversial issues gun rights
it's a unique issue generally it's a
losing issue for the gun grabbers
because even among Democrats there are
some people who are very serious about
keeping their second Amendment rights I
mean this is a basic civil right
guaranteed by our Constitution on the
issue of gun rights everybody knows
exactly how they feel about it okay
there is no ambiguity whatsoever when
you're talking about something like
criminal justice reform people don't
exactly know how they feel it's kind of
a new issue that's being discussed on
the right you've got libertarians who
tend to be a little more favorable
toward leniency so there's even debate
among right the left tends to want more
leniency in criminal justice so it's
just it's much more complicated it's
much less black and white even worse for
Mike Bloomberg who's trying to win the
Democratic nomination and he's spending
a lot of money doing it this alienates
some of the earliest Democratic voters
so what are the early democratic states
it's gonna be Iowa that that caucus is
happening tonight voters are going to
the polls in Iowa right now you've got
New Hampshire you've got Nevada
you've got South Carolina just those
first four states or maybe the most
pro-gun states that you're gonna get to
in the presidential primary why on earth
would you lead with this polarizing
issue it's just a loser of an ad it's
it's an approach that that just doesn't
take into account practical politics now
we need to take Mike Bloomberg seriously
we need to take him seriously because
he's got a lot of money so there was a
report out right now Mike Bloomberg so
far has spent 200 million dollars of his
own money in the first five weeks of his
campaign now that matters it wouldn't
matter how much money you spend that
matters because the DNC is corrupt so
the Democratic National Committee we've
known this for years
it's run by party elites who stole the
nomination from Bernie Sanders last time
Bernie Sanders is rising up in the polls
right now this time the DNC is changing
their debate rules
to allow Mike Bloomberg in my Klum burg
would not qualify for the Democratic
debates unless the DNC changed the rules
now other candidates have not qualified
for the debates Tulsi Gabbard Cory
Booker who Leon Castro that didn't
matter because those guys didn't have a
ton of money to donate to the DNC two
days before he jumped into this
presidential race Mike Bloomberg donated
over three hundred thousand dollars to
the DNC specifically he just maxed out
which you can give to the party and then
surprise surprise the DNC changes the
rules to let him in now why is why is
the DNC willing to do that is it only
for the money that Mike Bloomberg is
paying maybe that's part of it the other
reason is because they're looking at Joe
Biden and they're saying Joe Biden who's
the other old moderate guy in the race
he's collapsing he's falling apart we
can't rely on him to be our nominee and
to be Trump in November so if Biden
collapses Mike Bloomberg is willing to
take the moderate Lane and he could do
pretty well now president Trump is
taking this seriously even though Mike
Bloomberg has not great political
instincts and he aired this very dumb ad
during the Superbowl that's not gonna
help him at all he's got a lot of money
mayor of New York he knows how to work
the system and he's got a workable
system in the Democratic National
Committee that he can use to his
advantage so President Trump today
pre-super Bowl interview with Sean
Hannity and he went straight after
Bloomberg now pay attention to Trump's
line of attack on Mayor Mike Michael
Bloomberg very little I just think of
little you know now he wants a box for
the debates to stand on okay it's okay
there's nothing wrong you could be short
why should he get a box to stand on okay
he wants a box for the debates why
should he be in ton of that I really
then does that mean everyone else gets a
box he says I mean everybody else gonna
get a box a little mini Mike he started
calling a mini Mike
he's going after Bloomberg's height we
all know it's improper it's wrong it's
mean it's crude it's childish but in
terms of political attacks this is
probably one of trumps best attacks
first of all Mike Bloomberg
quite petite I have met Mike Bloomberg
I've been at events with Mike Bloomberg
the websites that say the Mike Bloomberg
is 5 foot 8 or 5 foot 9 or 5 foot 10 are
just simply lying he's not that tall
he's a very petite man now that's fine
there have been very impressive shorter
people in history napoleon bonaparte
being one example James Madison being
another example however the reason this
attack was so smart is not because Trump
is making fun of the guy for being short
it's because it's baiting Mike Bloomberg
to respond in kind and when Mike
Bloomberg responds in kind
he looks degraded he looks like he's
down in the dirt with Trump the attack
works Trump did this so successfully to
virtually every Republican in 2016
okay Mike Bloomberg Trump calls
Bloomberg short Bloomberg takes the bait
and totally screwed up the answer
Bloomberg spokesman said quote Trump is
a pathological liar who lies about
everything is fake hair his obesity and
his spray-on tan
alright Bloomberg just lost all the
moral high ground
Bloomberg just got right down in the
muck with Trump the GOP candidates in
2016 did the same thing they took
Trump's bait and they degraded
themselves the whole argument that they
were making take someone like Jeb Bush
Jeb Bush made this pitch which was
Donald Trump is juvenile he's cruel he's
crude he's undignified he's disgusting
right now Jeb Bush I am this serious
mature dignified person okay they could
have made that argument except when Bush
would degrade himself I remember one
specific moment one specific moment 2016
Jeb said something that was a little
more Trump II and Trump laughed at it
and Jeb said yeah was that high-energy
enough for you Donald and Donald said
you have pretty good and Donald put his
hand out low by his side as if to get a
low five and Jeb Bush like he had just
gotten the approval of the bully on the
playground gets so excited he kind of
jumps up a little any smacks Trump's
hand with a high five and right there
Jeb lost his whole campaign and he lost
his whole campaign
cause the only reason to vote for Jeb
Bush is that he is the boring mature
serious adult and Donald Trump aided him
into looking more childish than he
another example of this Marco Rubio by
Donald Trump starts calling all the
candidates name there's a little Marco
or at lyin Ted low-energy Jeb and Marco
Rubio was getting irritated by this but
he was trying to maintain that dignity
he was trying to maintain those those
talking points the memorized thirty
second speech as Chris Christie called
it and then when he was getting
desperate toward the end of the primary
race Rubio wanted to mix it up so he
starts taunting Donald Trump like he was
Don Rickles like he was doing an insult
comedy routine he made fun of Trump's
hand-sized insinuating that another part
of Donald Trump's anatomy was a little
small he started making fun of his
physicality and Marco fell apart because
now all of a sudden you didn't just have
one crude undignified candidate and one
serious foreign policy establishment guy
you had two undignified childish
candidates and if you're gonna pick one
of them you're obviously gonna pick
Trump because at least Trump is
authentic he's not trying to do
something else I think Donald Trump
actually made fun of him he said yeah
Rubio was at their doing his Rickles
routine but it's not gonna work you know
you can't you can't have Trump Trump
that's what happened here I think there
are a lot of moderate people especially
moderate Democrats who would really like
Mike Bloomberg very successful guy very
moderate very acceptable and yet if
Bloomberg is gonna go out there and be
like hey Donald you're fat and ugly and
stupid hahaha then all right if you've
got two brash tough-talking New Yorkers
who are undignified give me Trump at
least Trump has a good track record
right he's got a great economy great
foreign policy he's I'll take the devil
I know rather than the devil that I
don't so notice how Trump goes after the
other candidates compared to Mike
Bloomberg he goat he doesn't go after
Bloomberg on issues he goes after Bernie
on issues we'll see that in a second he
doesn't go after Bloomberg on guns
because President Trump knows the guns
are a tricky issue right
he he knows the lesson that Mike
Bloomberg doesn't know Mike Bloomberg
decides to lead during the Superbowl
everybody's watching by talking about
how he hates your guns and he's gonna
take your second Amendment rights away
immediately gonna alienate half the
audience Trump doesn't do that even
though Trump has the opposite position
on guns right Trump says I'm gonna
defend your Second Amendment but he
knows if he airs that ad he's going to
alienate half the audience if he goes
after Bloomberg on his signature issue
guns gonna lose half the audience so
instead he calls him short he calls him
weak and in the process of that he makes
Mike Bloomberg degrade himself much
smarter strategy
he saved the issue attacks and that same
pre-super Bowl interview for Bernie
Sanders here is Bernie Sanders well I
think he's a communist I mean you know
look I think of communism when I think
of Bernie now you could say socialist
but did they get married in Moscow and
that's wonderful Moscow's wonderful
honeymoon you don't think necessarily
well whatever but you don't necessarily
think in terms of marriage Moscow and
it's wonderful I'm not knocking it but I
think of Bernie sort of as a socialist
but far beyond the socialism there's the
issue attack there's the ideological
attack Bloomberg is short and weak and
he's gonna irritate Bloomberg so much
that he's going to implode Bernie is a
communist she doesn't call Bernie an old
crazy haired wild man right he calls him
a communist goes after what he thinks
as he should because but bernie is a
communist Trump as always is painting
this picture he got married in Moscow
and then then you hear well he didn't
get married in Moscow he did his
honeymoon in Moscow yeah honeymoon
marriage whatever the guide loves Moscow
okay in Moscow is a fine place but
communist it's and you're just getting
this image of Bernie so excited he loves
the Soviet Union so much that he's
getting married there he's honeymooning
there bernie is surging we're gonna see
tonight if Bernie's support is real
because bernie is now at the top of the
heap in Iowa now if Bernie doesn't win
in Iowa
it's a whole new race if Bernie does win
in Iowa if he's got momentum into New
Hampshire that is a serious problem for
the establishment if Joe Biden does
collapse tonight in Iowa and later in
New Hampshire
Bloomberg could be the guy he's got the
money he's got
the media right he's he's guy is that
actually as a media outlet called
Bloomberg his chief competition for this
moderate Lane would be mayor Pete Budaj
edge and senator Amy Klobuchar neither
are ready for primetime the Democratic
establishment is so nervous about this
John Kerry former Secretary of State and
failed presidential candidate in 2004
was overheard in a Des Moines hotel just
over the weekend suggesting that he
might run for president John Kerry got
clobbered in 2004
now he's denied this he actually tweeted
out a very profane quote I don't know
how else to put it it was clearly a
mistake that he tweeted it out he
deleted it later but he wrote quote as I
told the reporter I'm absolutely not
running for president any report
otherwise is effing or categorically
false I've been proud to campaign with
my good friend Joe Biden who's going to
win the nomination beat Trump and make
an outstanding president then he deleted
that cuz clearly someone drafted it up
and jokingly wrote effing right instead
of categorically and then they tweeted
that out
think about how desperate the Democrats
must be for John Kerry to have an
opening in this race
think about how pathetic that is John
Kerry got clobbered by George W Bush 16
years ago 16 years ago this would be
like if in 2012 the Republican Party was
in such disarray that they got Bob Dole
to run again Bob Dole ran got the
nomination in 1996 lost to Bill Clinton
it would be like if 16 years later 2012
he ran for president again we didn't
exactly have a winner in 2012 we had
mint freaking Romney but still at least
we had a kind of new candidate a younger
candidate it would be absurd to if the
party were in such bad shape that Bob
Dole were running again in 2012 you'd be
in immense trouble and that is what
we're seeing here among the Democrats so
I think in so much as there was politics
in the Superbowl the Republicans did
much better they've just played it much
smarter
other than that the Super Bowl was not
terribly political they made a big point
of this because they're finally seeing
their ratings come back after years of
falling apart post Colin Kaepernick and
they just didn't want to ruin it there
was one ad that the Superbowl rejected
that was so so offensive so absurd that
they just they dismissed it outright
that was from PETA
it was PETA comparing black people to
animals we will get to that in a second
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube and sorry guys
because you're gonna miss my halftime
show thoughts and I have many thoughts
about the halftime show
speaking of halftime it feels like we're
halfway through 2020 but the truth is we
haven't even gotten started the election
race is just heating up and because we
know that you need to stay up-to-date we
are giving 20% off all memberships 20%
off all memberships when you use the
promo code DW 2020 members get our
articles ad free access to all of our
live broadcasts and show library the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now election insight op-eds
from ben shapiro plus our new all-access
tier gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben drew and Matt
Walsh plus our website's writers and
special guests us we answer and the
leftist tears tumblr just Gloup Gloup
Gloup Gloup blood fills right up
download the daily wire app a member
exclusive so that you can get push
notifications straight to your phone
that is promo code DW 2024 20% off join
today and stay informed on all things
2020 and then don't forget to tune in
tomorrow for a special backstage we I'm
so excited for backstage tomorrow
because it's been far too long since
I've had a cigar it's been like 20 or 30
hours at this point so be sure to tune
in there go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
before we get to the halftime show which
is visually rather interesting I've got
to talk about this ad that the Super
Bowl and the NFL rejected this was an ad
by PETA
comparing black people to animals
take a listen I will narrate you through
this ad so you've got a little bumblebee
flying and then the animals start
kneeling you can see a little bear bear
standing up then the bear kneels down a
little fish swimming in the water the
fish kneels down wolves foxes they take
a knee a disgusting tarantula and a
gross little rat nail a kneel down sheep
dog kneels down little pig kneel Stan
you can hear this star-spangled banner
the background reminds you of that Colin
Kaepernick protests all the animals
kneeling down
[Music]
now the bald eagle itself is kneeling
down symbol of America and the final the
final line is hashtag end
speciesism so this is so bonkers I've
seen PETA make this argument before I
remember I saw it in college they had
they had a PETA protest in college and
they had these big billboards and it
showed African chattel slavery like
full-on African men in Chains in the
19th century and then cows on a farm and
they were saying you know see when you
really think about it aren't those the
same thing and in order for those to be
the same thing then black people have to
be animals those have to be the same
thing and I remember standing there with
several of my friends who were most of
whom were liberal by the way and we're
just looking at it like have you people
lost your minds do you understand how
horribly offensive this is now for
Peters perspective they don't think it's
offensive any reasonable person would
look at it and say hey you're calling
black people animals like maybe don't do
that but from Peters perspective because
they like animals much more than people
they're saying no no we're just saying
all species are the same and so they all
need to be treated exactly the same way
and that's what they're drawing a direct
comparison between racism which was
ostensibly the purpose of the flag
kneeling Colin Kapernick protest and
speciesism in other words we shouldn't
draw any distinctions between races
because we're all children of God and
likewise we shouldn't draw any
distinction between an amine human
beings and spiders because we're all the
same thing really when you think about
it now this isn't true at all I mean the
reason that we we treat animals
differently than human beings is because
human beings have will and intellect and
animals do not this is the same reason
by the way that we don't arrest a fox if
a little fox rapes and other Fox in the
in the wild animals rape each other all
the time right but but it's not really
rape because animals don't have free
will and intellect so it's not like
they're violating some moral law
they're aware of they did they have a
conscience telling them to act in
accordance with the transcendent moral
order and then they decide to sin by
transgressing that no do we arrest a
wolf for eating another animal no do we
charge the the bear with murder against
the salmon no of course not because
animals are different than people Peter
couldn't see it that way I think the NFL
very wisely saw the blowback that they
would get from that ad PETA PETA
incredibly released it on their own and
they're they're rightly getting blowback
for that as well absolute craziness but
good on the NFL because the NFL was his
saw that over the past two years since
they cut out the flag kneeling they got
past Colin Kaepernick their ratings
started to creep back up when Colin
Kaepernick protested the American flag
on TV and then a whole bunch of other
NFL players started to protest the flag
the NFL ratings tanked all the defenders
of Kaepernick all of the left is said oh
it's all their only tanking because
people are watching as much TV it's a
coincidence it's not about the flag
protest well ok then how do you explain
the NFL ratings coming back in 2018 2019
ticking up five percent year-over-year
it's because they got rid of that so the
NFL wised up they even had a tribute to
the American flag before the game I
walked through a County Courthouse
Square
on a park bench an old man sitting there
I said yo courthouse is kind of rundown
he said no it'll do for our little town
I said you old flagpole is leaning a
little bit that's a racket over the flag
he got hanging on it
he said have a seat and I stay down is
this the first time you've been to our
little town I said I think it is he said
I don't like to brag but we're kind of
proud
well that sure is a different tune from
what we've been hearing from the NFL the
last few years right the last few years
have been the American flag is awful we
got to protest it we're gonna protest
the star-spangled banner we're going to
protest the symbol of our country Colin
Kaepernick protesting a flag from the
Revolutionary War long before we had
police departments and alleged police
brutality now all of a sudden we're
getting the most sentimental pro-america
flag wave and I'm proud of that ragged
old flag might as well have George Cohan
over there marching saying it's a grand
old flag it's a high flying flag now
what this teaches us is actually very
hopeful it's that you can turn things
around you can make a comeback it's not
over until it's over whether that's in
sports whether that's in politics
whether it's for our country the Chiefs
were losing the game yesterday and then
at the very end of the game they turned
it around and they won president Trump
was losing the game in 2016 ninety nine
percent chance Hillary was gonna win and
then guess what we won
looked like we were careening into
leftist decay and then turned it all
around the NFL was completely collapsing
they were in freefall and then they just
got rid of all their nonsense this
anti-american stuff started waving an
American flag every so often realized
that sports always have something to do
with national unity national loyalty
brought that back and guess what they
turn that around as well it's a it's an
important thing for us to remember as we
as we lament our culture falling apart
politics falling apart our government
falling apart you can turn it around
they were gonna impeach Trump remember
the impeach Trump then they weren't
gonna they weren't gonna kick him out of
office they didn't have the votes for
that but they were gonna drag this out
for months and months and months and
guess what happened at the very end a
few Republican senators changed their
mind and we got the end of impeachment
which we'll get to in a second but
before we move on from the super while I
do want to just mention this halftime
show which is getting a lot of traction
around this involved Shakira and JLo you
can pretty much sum the halftime show up
in two seconds here it is
Meritus it's just Shakira Shakira and
JLo shaking their moneymakers
that was the halftime show look not the
worst halftime show in the world I'll
take it over Nickelback but it also
showed us something about art and about
culture right this whole show
especially the JLo side of it was
explicitly pornographic and involved a
stripper pole grinding crotch grabbing
some rope was involved both Shakira and
JLo are incredibly skilled dancers and
performers they're incredibly hot
they're just it's unbelievable JLo is I
think 50 years old now Shakira is 43
they were moving like they were
teenagers I mean they're just incredibly
skilled performers and yet this show
wasn't that sexy even it was all about
sex it still wasn't that sexy it
reminded me that pornographic is
actually the opposite of sexy it seems
like they would be the same thing but
they're actually opposites and I'll give
you an example I was in Cuba a couple
years ago and we went to one of these
old timey Cuban shows kind of the Ricky
Ricardo stuff you know where the women
come out in the big costumes and they're
kind of moving their hips and they're
not actually showing you that much of
their body but the way that they're
moving the things that they are slightly
revealing and then putting back away
create sexiness sexiness comes from what
you're not showing as well it's it's the
reason that a woman in a bikini is
sexier than a woman who's completely
naked a lot of the time why is that it's
because when you just show everything
it's all out there in many ways that's
grotesque people generally don't all
look that good naked but when you're
hiding something then your imagination
is doing the work it's the reason why
you never want to see the monster in the
horror movie the minute you see the
monster it's all clear to you you don't
have anything left to imagine or
anything left to be excited about or
anything left to dread or any of that
but when the monster is in the shadows
you can't then your imagination is doing
so much more work it's the reason that
modern
a tree is trash and older poetry that
has constraints is good it's a reason
that's you know slam poetry is like the
death of art is there's no limitation on
it there's nothing constraining it
whereas an Elizabethan sonnet has all of
these rules that you've got to play
within and the constraints actually give
much more creativity our culture has
become increasingly pornographic and and
much less sexy the whole time and it's
just a legend I think for young people
and performers to keep in mind is you
need a limiting principle in in all
walks of life if you just throw it all
out there if you just get so graphic and
grotesque then you're actually losing a
lot of what you're going for in the
first place
got to restrain yourself you've got to
have some rules you've got to leave a
little bit to the imagination because
the imagination it has a much more power
than our limited physical bodies that
was just my take on it I'm not saying
look could have been a worse halftime
show I know a lot of conservatives are
railing against the explicit nature of
it think of the children all the
children will be traumatized that's not
my primary concern I mean it's true you
don't want kids to be seeing these very
graphic things at a family sporting
event but my concern is beyond the
children my concern is just that it's
actually not achieving what it says that
it will achieve you know that that it's
in the same way that the sexual
revolution actually now means that fewer
people are having sex that now actually
were it's a it's having the opposite
effect of what it said it was doing and
that's so often the case with leftist
cultural movements there was another
huge comeback which happened just after
we went off air on Thursday which is
that President Trump is about to be
exonerated - President Trump is almost
certainly about to be acquitted in his
impeachment trial there were four
senators four Republican senators who
could have tanked this impeachment made
it go dragged on for weeks and weeks and
weeks with more witnesses and john
bolton testifying and hunter
Biden testifying in the whistleblower
testifying Adam Schiff testifying or
they could have all ended it I you know
I'm doing this show with Senator Ted
Cruz called verdict with Ted Cruz and he
comes from the capital each night comes
on over and we talk about what happened
in impeachment so we had been chatting
the night before this this vote last
week and he said oh yeah it's probably
gonna drag on it looks like we're gonna
get some witnesses we'll see if we can
move some senators four senators here
Mitt Romney Susan Collins Lisa Murkowski
and Lamar Alexander those were the four
Republicans had about forty seven votes
they needed three of those they needed
three people to flip or I'm sorry rather
the Democrats needed needed three or
four people to flip and then they could
have dragged out this impeachment
question if they only got three people
to flip then we would have had a 50/50
vote on more witnesses we don't know how
that would have resolved the Chief
Justice would have been dragged into it
anyway he chose whether to vote or to it
not to vote or to let the motion die it
would have created a real constitutional
problem so they were going to try to
drag out these votes now what happened
Mitt Romney and Susan Collins both said
they were gonna vote for more witnesses
so the Democrats just needed to get one
more to make it to 50/50 or two more to
make it to 5149 the other two were Lisa
Murkowski and Lamar Alexander Lisa
Murkowski is an independent she's a
moderate from Alaska it's a purple state
she had to go home and face her
constituents Lamar Alexander was
retiring so he actually didn't have that
constituent problem Lamar Alexander
though as Senator Lindsey Graham and
senator Cruz were telling me the other
night on the verdict podcast Lamar
Alexander really cares about the
institution of the Senate he didn't want
to see the institution of the Senate
lose respecting credibility now when in
particular Lindsey Graham and Ted Cruz
we're trying to work the room and try to
work the senators and get them to come
over and vote against witnesses they had
to use different tactics they had to
convince senator Murkowski that it was
in her interest
to go in vote against witnesses and and
did that would help her with her
constituents they had to convince
senator Alexander that it would hurt the
credibility of the US Senate if he voted
for more witnesses those are totally
different lines of attack they had to
know that Mitt Romney and Susan Collins
were lost causes and Susan Collins again
purple state she's in an election year
he can kind of understand it Mitt Romney
has no excuse he's just a jerk he's just
an absolute jerk he's in a very
conservative state of Utah and he's
still a jerk but even his jerk vote
tells us something about this process
which is that the individuals matter
it's the lesson I've learned most on the
verdicts podcast with with senator Cruz
we go we think that going into these
impeachment proceedings everything is
pre-planned everything is scripted
nothing happens in real time it does the
left tells us in history individuals
don't matter it's all just big trends
it's all gonna play out inevitably we
don't really have free will we do the
individuals do matter if Ted Cruz and
Lindsey Graham had not been trying to
persuade Lisa Murkowski and Lamar
Alexander then very likely we would have
witnesses this impeachment trial would
be dragging on if Mitt Romney didn't
hate Donald Trump and if Donald Trump
hadn't been kind of mean to Mitt Romney
and if Mitt Romney frankly hadn't
started it then Romney very likely would
have voted to acquit President Trump
would have voted against further
witnesses wouldn't have even had to
worry about this other stuff the
individuals here are really important
they're really important to politics and
that I guess that kind of plays in with
the whole theme of the day which is
making a comeback which is that an
individual really can make a difference
and you really can change the course of
the game the course of the trial in the
course of history so what happens now
Democrats are going to try to derail
this we had the vote last week against
more witnesses that for all intents and
purposes ended the discussion now you're
gonna have some proceedings this week
and then on Wednesday of this week
you're going to have the final vote of
whether to convict President Trump and
remove him from office and prevent him
from running in November because if a
president's been in
and removed he can't run for office
again or are they going to vote to
acquit and say that he's not guilty it
almost certainly will be the latter
there's no evidence that Trump committed
any crime the Democrats in the house
aren't even charging him with a crime so
the Democrats will try to derail it the
Senate will try will will probably vote
to acquit and then I think the Democrats
will try to impeach him again they can
impeach him again they can impeach him
for something else they didn't charge
him with a crime this time they program
with Georgian with a crime next time but
I think they will vote or at least
attempt to impeach him again why because
this is the first time we've ever had a
fully partisan impeachment in American
history and if it's a fully partisan
impeachment and then it's a there's
actually a bipartisan movement against
impeachment but if it's fully partisan
they'll just keep doing it because it
doesn't matter if Trump commits a crime
or not they're just gonna vote for it
Joni Ernst Republican senator thinks the
same thing she said quote I think this
door of impeachable whatever has been
opened Joe Biden should be very careful
what he's asking for because you know we
can have a situation where if it should
ever be President Biden then immediately
people right the day after he would be
elected would be saying well we're going
to impeach him we might be in the era of
impeachment as one of president Trump's
lawyers Ken Starr said during the
arguments we might now be in a position
where impeachment is just a regular tool
of partisan politics that's a sad
situation to be in but the Democrats
started it we can't unilaterally disarm
they could change it individuals matter
in politics but they need to show that
they can change it one way that they
could do it would be during this this
Senate vote on Wednesday if Democrats
vote to acquit the president if they
make this a bipartisan acquittal if they
do that then that might go a long way
toward ending this age of impeachment
before it really begins one can hope
before we go got to talk about another
huge comeback that would be brexit
brexit has officially happened Britain
has officially left the European Union
are you okay are you alive
has there been mass death mass
starvation no it's fine everything is
fine they told us it would be awful and
now it's fine they told us we would die
everybody's okay
we're already obviously dead from tax
cuts and the repeal of net neutrality
but we were all really supposed to die
from Rexach right except it didn't
happen everything's fine and the most
telling headline is from the New York
Times New York Times posted yesterday
quote what if brexit works Britain is
remaking itself again the shape of its
society and economy and its place in the
world are very much up for grabs
Britain's departure from the EU on
Friday drum mournful reaction for many
people who have long viewed brexit as
consigning their country once the
vanguard of Europe to a future of
economic mediocrity and geopolitical
irrelevance but there are many others
who view brexit as a day of liberation
when Britain unshackled from the
bureaucracy of Brussels will stride into
a future of economic innovation and
vigorous clear-eyed politics a moment of
national renewal disruptive change can
be beneficial for a country said Tony
Travers a professor of politics that is
in a sense what brexit has accomplished
after three and a half years of debate
the question what if it works we had
been told for certain it won't work we
had been trolled that if Trump was
elected we'd all die the economy would
collapse we'd go into World War 3 it'd
be nuclear holocaust we had been told
brexit would kill us all right and then
it did not happen they were wrong
there's a headline from the New
Statesman in June of 2016 the headline
was calm down Trump won't be president
in Britain won't leave the EU they have
insisted particularly the progressives
the left that there is just a pathum in
the future we are heading toward
progress what you want what you desire
what you think about does not matter
what you individuals do does not matter
history is marching inevitably toward
progress it's in the very name
progressive and William F Buckley Jr and
when he was started National Review in
the first issue he said a conservative
is one who stands the thwart history
yelling stop and individuals have done
that before they've turned it all around
they've come from behind in the game in
politics and the impeachment trial in
the history of the world we're seeing
that happen over and over and over and
it does appear that we are at a period
of renewal we are at the dawn of
something new whether that something new
will turn out well or turn out poorly is
not written in stone it's not inevitable
the individuals will matter we have a
chance to come from behind but we've got
to take that chance all right that's our
show I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show head on over to daily
wire.com get that 20% off subscription
and then I will see you back here
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson
hair and makeup Jessa alvera production
assistants McKenna Waters and Ryan love
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you